the location in new york city is
established during the opening title
sequence where we see huge looming text
over skyscrapers in manhattan eventually
zeroing in on times square the home of
many world-class broadway shows
these theatrical performances don't have
the luxury of jumping around from
location to location and can oftentimes
be set in a single place
relying entirely on strong performances
from each character to carry the show
the same can be said of david fincher's
2002 film panic room
outside of short intro and outro scene
the entirety of the movie takes place
inside this house which
fittingly is a giant set where the
script was shot in chronological order
the nice thing about our movie was that
we actually shot the entire film in the
sequence
everything happened exactly as it
happens in the film we got to shoot from
beginning to end if these shots are a
hints of the audience
to buckle in for a broadway-like horror
suspense thriller the electronic
billboard gives us a clue as to what the
main character is going to go through
it flashes out a message base your fears
something that our claustrophobic hero
meg altman will have to come to term
with after she and her daughter are
forced to take cover in the tiny
confines of the panic room
open it please and with kids like he's
apparently got no wonder he wanted a
place to hide
please open the door that is highly
inappropriate open the door
please but the fear of small spaces
wouldn't be the only obstacle that meg
would have to overcome
to learn the connection to david
fincher's sophomore film sasebo
and the truth about how ms altman
alerted the police without her
daughter's captors finding out stick
around to the end of this video
welcome to things you missed in today's
episode i'll be covering the apparently
underappreciated panic room
the only thing i don't really get about
panic rooms is why they're called panic
rooms i mean they're supposed to be the
safest place in the house right
so they should really be called don't
panic rooms or the stay calm room
nobody panic i'm going to roll
the logo
early on in the film we were given a
tour of the property stop
calling it the property it sounds
ridiculous actually what may look like a
tour of the
house is really setting up for the
backstory of this movie we're given
snippets of information about the
previous owner
sydney pearlstein one line in particular
tells us most of what we need to know
his kids are suing each other over the
estate
he was a reckless rich paranoid now it
turns out they can't find out his money
we later find out that one of those kids
is the burglar jr
also known as cornrow letto
another important detail explains why
meg is uncomfortable with tight spaces
this whole thing makes me nervous why
ever read any poe no but i loved her
last album
update in 2020 haunted is still her last
album but meg wasn't talking about the
singer pose she's referencing our boy
edgar allen
more specifically she's probably talking
about his short horror story the
premature burial which is about a man
with catalepsy a condition that can
cause you to fall into a trance where
you lose your consciousness and your
body goes rigid
giving the appearance of a corpse
because of this the man becomes paranoid
of being buried alive his fear stems
from claustrophobia which is exactly
what makes meg uncomfortable about the
panic room when the two altman girls are
trapped in the room later the daughter
sarah tries to calm her down by saying
that people never get buried alive
anymore
i guess it used to happen all the time
sarah has a condition of her own which
is also set up in the early going when
we see her medication in the fridge her
mom limiting how much soda is poured in
her glass
and the blood sugar monitor that she
wears to bed the camera work in this
movie is nothing short of
ridiculous it not only does a great job
of establishing the layout of the house
and showing us just how close meg and
sarah are to the intruders when they
break in but it also has this perfect
machine-like flow that represents the
burglar's methodical approach to
breaking and entering we also see the
camera passing through objects and
passing through walls but for the
burglars passing through solid matter is
the one thing that they'd like to do
that they can't
in my episode of things you missed on
sevenand i explained how the main
conflict in the movie is a lot like a
chess match and according to
cinematographer conrad hall a similar
analogy exists in panic room
this was always i think for him a chess
game he wanted the audience to be
completely
involved in seeing everything knowing
everything in many cases
before the characters know them in the
movie the audience knows exactly where
everybody is
in the chess game at that moment in
addition to the camera work the film
editing is also used in
very creative ways i love this part
where cutting away is used to censor
profanity
she's lying you're full of
and when meg eventually taps into the
phone line to try to call for help
the movie is cut so that we only hear
what her ex-husband steven hears
there are three men upstairs they broke
into
steven's new girlfriend who is the first
to pick up the phone when meg calls is
voiced by actress nicole kidman who was
previously cast to play meg but had to
drop out due to a knee injury
they actually shot for three weeks with
nicole before jody foster had to be
brought in to replace her so jody
replaced nicole in the movie but
nicole replaced jody in the marriage in
the movie
but there would be another interesting
cameo in panic room when we're
introduced to the neighbor across the
way who's the key to finding even more
things you missed
[Music]
in a moment of desperation sarah
eventually discovers a ventilation hole
to the outside and uses a flashlight to
try to send a message to their neighbor
the neighbor who is credited as
sleepy neighbor is played by andrew
kevin walker who was the screenwriter of
susevnan
that means that the three central
characters of 7n detective somerset
detective mills and
john doe are his creations i think these
three all have spiritual successors in
panic room
force whitaker plays burnham a smart
calm logical voice of reason he's only
in on the heist because he wants a
better life for his kid
similar to how detective somerset may
have used illegal tactics to help locate
john doe but it came from a good place
because he was fighting for a better
world
cornrow leto plays junior the young
inexperienced burglar with a short
temper who gets in way over his head he
brought burnham and raul together for
the heist so he's technically in charge
but like detective mills and sasebonen
he doesn't quite know what he's gotten
himself into
and defaults to the others for hell then
there's dwight yocam as raoul
he's the crazy one but rarely loses his
temper he's always cool and calculating
even as he negotiates a higher cut of
the money that they're planning to steal
his entire personality and demeanor is
very similar to john doe
who are you i'm wrong
it doesn't matter who i am who i am
means absolutely nothing
so here are my spiritual succession
characters but i should also note that
you
could make a case for switching junior
and raoul because
and this is a spoiler alert for 7n so
skip ahead if you haven't seen it
raul is the one who takes out junior
similar to what mills eventually does to
john doe
and raul's left hand is injured when he
accidentally pinches it in the panic
room door
just as mills hurts his hand in the
chase with john doe so in that case you
could say that junior is john doe
because it was all his plan to bring
everyone together
like jon brought everyone together at
the end of ceceviden and raul is mills
because he lets his rage get the better
of him when he beats up steven who shows
up to try to save the girls
and it's also possible that none of this
was intentional at all but there's no
doubt that david fincher's directorial
trademarks are responsible for some
similarities between these films like
the fact that it's raining for the
majority of both movies but he wasn't
the only one to leave his mark on this
film
that's right i'm talking about sony
let's go back to the very beginning
columbia pictures a sony pictures
entertainment company
in the panic room sony monitors next to
the monitors
a sony telephone the entire house
covered by sony
cameras i'm just surprised they didn't
give sarah a pair of spyro pajamas and
have her recite
michael jackson albums when she gets
nervous the product placement in this
movie is just
out of control what
the big question that always comes up
when you talk about panic room is
the ending burnham goes back to save the
family from raul and the police show up
to arrest him before he can get away as
he puts his hands up
22 million swirls away and is lost in
the wind but the question that everybody
seems to ask is how the police knew to
come back
after this scene which took place
earlier that night when the cops showed
up after receiving calls from meg
stephen and a neighbor raul and burnham
are with sarah in the panic room and
they make it clear that something bad
will happen
if she tries anything suspicious with
the cops she lets them know that she's
going to try to send them away in
exchange for her daughter's safety right
here
she also knows that the thieves are
watching her every move on the video
cameras the cameras aren't equipped
with audio but she also knows that there
are two of them in there so one of them
could sneak down to listen in on the
conversation
so as far as we can tell during that
scene she sends the cops away without
raising the alarm and burnham and raul
still think they have a chance to get
away with it however if we take a closer
look at the scene we can see that meg is
very deliberate about this interaction
with the police earlier on when she was
temporarily able to hook up the phone
line she made two calls the first was to
the police who put her on hold so she
promptly hangs up and makes the second
call to her ex-husband
remember she was in the panic room when
she made these calls so the bad guys
didn't hear either of them
she's able to use that to her advantage
by giving subtle clues to the cops that
something doesn't add up roll it
you got a call man somebody called you
this is the first sign that something is
up she was the first one to make a call
and now she's acting like it never
happened
then look at this next part can we come
in
what do you want we'd like to come in
pause it right there as she steps back
she leans against the second door
opening it ever so slightly so that the
cop can see the couch pushed up against
the door and
possibly the man bleeding out in the
living room then she turns away to close
the inner door
calling even more attention to it but
perhaps the most important part of this
conversation
is this there are three
your husband said you called for help
that you said
there were three right before you got
cut off what was
the end of that sentence so meg makes up
a story about how she drunkenly called
her ex-husband and said there are three
things that she would do if he drove
over and hopped in bed with her right
now but she came to her senses and hung
up mid-sentence but if we go back to
even earlier in that night to examine
that phone call she says
you gotta help us there are three men so
this is the perfect lie to tell them
because she knows that it's wrong the
cops know that it's wrong and the
robbers know that it's wrong
but the robbers don't know that the cops
know that it's wrong they think she's
making a good excuse
and then there's one final test ma'am
if there's something you want to say to
us
but maybe you can't say it right now
you might want to make some kind of a
signal
by blinking your eyes a few times
something like that
and we never see meg blink her eyes but
the scene cuts back to the close-up of
the officer
so it's left unknown for the rest of the
movie if she blinked at him while she
was off screen
but after seeing the ending i think she
did give a signal and the cop was smart
enough to put all of those pieces
together and know that it wasn't the
right time for them to storm into the
house but perhaps an even
bigger mystery is why there isn't a
blu-ray available for this movie i mean
sony has already demonstrated that they
want to promote the heck out of
themselves by drenching this movie in
product placement so it seems like a
no-brainer to put this beloved film
on blu-ray and it'll probably have ads
for sony movies inside the box and
trailers it's a win-win for everyone so
you know what internet let's make this
happen i'm gonna put a link in the
description let's get this thing going
and hey if you love horror you don't
need to panic because you're in
the right place i'm going to be covering
all of david fincher's horror thriller
type movies i mean most of them are
probably more thriller mystery but
that's okay if there's suspense
or creepiness like in this case jared
leto's haircut i'm game to cover it and
you'll find that playlist
over on the left remember to subscribe
to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring that death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we stay inside of the panic
room